Speaker 1: Let's go to James from Southern
California.
James from Southern California.
Welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today, sir?
Speaker 4: Thank you very much.
David, are you able to hear me okay?
Speaker 1: I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 4: I want to start by thanking you
for everything you do.
I really appreciate all you've done over the
years on your program.
I have a comment and I have a question.
Sure.
One comment I want to make regarding the people
with the MAGA mentality.
I really want to encourage everyone to be
patient with these folks because we can get
through to them.
I've had a lot of success.
And I think the approach I use is very important
in remembering that they do live in fear to
some extent, very much happen to us in their
mentality.
Oh, yeah.
And if you can establish that you are one
of them and we are us.
They will listen to you.
And as long as you don't tell them they're
wrong, but simply give them information, but
build from the bottom up, remembering that
they're ignorant like little children.
And you need to use terms and concepts.
And once you have them on your side and they're
agreeing with you, you can start correcting
the misinformation that's in their head and
help them kind of re build their view of reality.
Speaker 1: I don't disagree with that one
bit.
Speaker 4: It takes a lot of patience.
Yes.
And I really want to encourage people to go
out to friends, family members who are frustrating
you and try to approach them as they are a
little child.
Speaker 1: Well, here's the thing, James.
Everything you're saying is correct.
The important thing to remember is that's
like a retail strategy person by person.
And it's insanely time consuming.
Doesn't mean we don't do it, but it is insanely
time consuming.
We also want to see, is there some wholesale
approach that might deprogram larger numbers
of these people?
And that's a tougher question to answer.
Speaker 4: It is indeed.
But I believe we need to approach this from
the grassroots because we all have a friend
or family member that we are probably avoiding.
Instead, we need to help them, right?
We need to help our community.
And I think it's a big part.
It's on us.
Rather than letting it happen.
We need to be patient.
Speaker 3: And take the time.
And yes, it is time consuming, but it does
work.
Speaker 4: It can be done.
I have faith in that and I just wanted to
make that comment fair because many of us
are feeling a little hopeless.
But don't give up on it, you know, take that
stand.
Anyway, I have a question for you.
Sure.
I was wondering, what do you think the odds
are of Tucker Carlson ending up on Newsmax?
Speaker 1: That's a good question.
You know, I have I have no idea.
I don't think I have anything substantive
or objective that I could say.
Could Tucker Carlson end up on Newsmax?
I know the CEO of Newsmax, interestingly enough,
he's kind of like a fan of my work.
Interestingly, even though our political views
are very, very different.
He is at heart a business person.
And so without a doubt, if I had to bet, I
would bet that he's looking to see what could
happen, maybe with Tucker Carlson on Newsmax.
My instinct is that it would be neither prestigious
nor lucrative enough for Tucker Carlson to
join.
I think Tucker Carlson would have more to
gain from launching his own thing from scratch.
But it's not impossible.
I don't know where Tucker is going to end
up.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I don't either.
I'm worried about that.
I was just wondering about your take on that.
Well, thank you so much, David.
I really appreciate everything you do for
us.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
James from Southern California.
Very, very good to hear from you.
Why don't we go next to Burt in New Jersey?
Burt in New Jersey.
Welcome to The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 3: Hey, Jumping right in again, calling
you for another Wednesday.
I won't pretend to be in work also.
All right.
I want to ask you.
I think it was Rolling Stone magazine reported
a couple weeks ago that when Trump got arraigned,
he had the option to do it over Zoom from
Mar a Lago and not go into Manhattan.
I don't know if you heard anything about this,
whether that's true, because if it is, that's
significant where, you know, he complains
about New York City spending all this money
and everything all could've been avoided.
The circus can be avoided had he done that.
Speaker 1: I am not aware that Trump was given
the opportunity to be arraigned via Zoom.
Let's see if I search for that.
Trump Arraignment via Zoom Opportunity.
Fact Check.
Did Trump refuse arraignment over Zoom from
Mar a Lago?
There was a tweet posted about that.
What is the verdict?
Unnamed sources only and no actual verified
evidence.
So at this point, it is at best an unverified
claim.
So, I mean, listen, either way, I've not seen
anything verified that Trump could have stayed
at Mar a Lago.
What I do know is that that court was not
doing anything over Zoom for a while now.
Now, whether they would have made a special
exception for Trump, maybe.
But Trump said he wanted the whole pomp and
circumstance.
He wanted to be handcuffed.
He wanted a mug shot, supposedly because he
thought it would help him.
So I don't know if any of that is true.
I can't imagine Trump would have wanted to
do it by Zoom.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Interesting thing to follow in case that turns
out to be true.
Yeah.
Now one more question to urge you on the Patriot
David podcast.
Yeah.
That I you know if I was great, I it's so
such a breath of fresh air to hear instead
of just the typical cable news propaganda.
You have two people with conflicting ideologies
like recognize each other's logic.
Right.
It's so rewarding to hear.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, I don't know about sometimes there
wasn't much logic, I have to tell you, Bert,
but I know what you're saying.
At least hearing the rationale.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
There were instances where he was forced to
kind out his head and go, Okay, you know,
I know.
I have no rebuttal for that.
Yeah, no, those are that are critical key
moments.
Question I have and I think all your audience
members is also wondering too, when are you
going to sit down, do round two with Ben SHAPIRO?
Because we would love.
Speaker 1: We Ben SHAPIRO hasn't been on,
I think, for like ten years.
We've invited him multiple times.
He never responds.
And, you know, he doesn't have any responsibility
to me.
He's he's he's way bigger than I am.
And he may be just too busy for me.
And that's totally fine.
But we've invited him a bunch of times.
It's up to him when we sit down again, not
up to me.
I'm willing to do it any time.
Speaker 3: Awesome.
Awesome to hear.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Bert from Jersey.
All good questions.
Very important stuff and different things
going on